pour public sénat en partenariat avec l'
afp les échos radio classique présente
eric woerth le président les
républicains de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté de
participer à ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp avec les échos et avec
radio classique trois grandes questions
vous seront posées au cours de cette
émission un emmanuel macron est il en
train de sortir la france de l'ornière
un indice économique plutôt favorable et
puis réforme grand cascades vous
répondrez à jean francis pécresse 2
laurent wauquiez qui est bien placé pour
prendre la tête de votre mouvement à la
mi-décembre peut-il rassembler la droite
nadège pull jacques viendra vous posez
la question enfin trois seulement entrer
dans un nouveau monde où est-ce toujours
le règne aujourd'hui de la vieille
politique mais qu'ils abaissent de
public sénat vous a préparé une batterie
de questions sur cette thématique mais
d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
on a parlé de la fin des privilèges avec
la réforme des frais de mandat pour les
députés 1 il y aura désormais des
dépenses interdite comme un achat
immobilier
est-ce que vous approuvez le contrôle
qui va rester très aléatoire pas du tout
systématique de ces frais c'est 5375
euros mensuels en plus bien sûr de votre
indemnité ont d'abord il faut une
enveloppe de frais comme parce que parce
que les parlementaires comme tous les
professionnels ont des bons évidemment
des défunts il fallait pas que cette ce
débat provoque une forme de populisme
vis-à-vis des parlementaires on est
habitué à l'anti-parlementarisme aussi
vieux que la démocratie et ça continuera
probablement mais en même temps il faut
que ce soit pour de bonnes raisons mais
pas pour de mauvaises raisons dont le
fait qu'ils aient une évolution de
l'utilisation des frais de mandat et
notamment la nécessité de justifier ses
frais mais à partir d'une série de
dépenses autorisé des catégories de
dépenses qui sont autorisés donc et des
catégories de dépenses qui ne le sont
pas ça me semble aller dans le sens
d'une une forme de transparence
voilà je pense que c'est important il
faudra que ce soit contrôlée au sein de
l'assemblée nationale
et puis je crois que ce sera le cas
entre la déontologue et les plans du
foot n'est de l'assemblée nationale et
c'est la même chose au sénat des
dépenses deviennent donc interdite ça
veut dire qu'il y avait des dépenses
personnelles ou même d enrichissement
personnel de la part de certains députés
à partir du moment où une liste de
dépenses autorisé sûr qu'il ya des
dépenses qui sont pas autorisées ces
pratiques étaient leurs délices je n'en
sais rien je pense que je pense que
probable en tout système connaît ses
excès toute la bâtisse thème humains qui
ne connaissent pas d'excès dont
probablement celui là
aussi voilages ans j'en sais pas plus
alors vous avez vu que le chef de l'état
durant sa campagne voulait aller
beaucoup plus loin parce que lui il
proposait pour les parlementaires
un remboursement sur note donc ça ne va
pas ça ne va pas jusque là
enfin que ce soit le cas pour le chef de
l'état lui-même d'ailleurs entre donc de
chef de l'état applique très souvent aux
autres ceux qui ne s'applique pas à lui
même c'est vrai pour emmanuel macron est
sans doute vrai pour tous ses
prédécesseurs
c'est vrai aussi pour les ministres donc
je veux juste faire attention
il ya quand même toujours une volonté de
l'exécutif qu'il a cette fois ci mon
avis est très prononcé d'essayer
d'affaiblir le parlement
c'était assez clair alors on le prend on
essaie de l'affaiblir en en mettant un
peut-être mais en mettant en montrant du
doigt les parlementaires ça a été le cas
dans cette dans la première loi la
première loi du quinquennat a porté sur
la moralisation entre guillemets de la
vie publique se voulait dire que la
moralisation rit ça voulait dire qu'ils
avaient immoralité delà de la vie
publique
c'était pas le gouvernement voir on ne
va rien à voir là dedans c'est évident
toujours le même heure un peu par le
parlement moralisation et puis
affaiblissement du parlement je pense
que c'est non mais je pense que nul
n'est obligé de faire la première loi
d'un quinquennat là dessus ça veut bien
dire que à ce moment là on considère
qu'il ya une vraie immoralité du
parlement des parlementaires et donc on
affaiblit ou à moins qu'il faut le
prouver dans ce cas là si c'est pas le
cas et je crois que ce n'est pas le cas
à ce moment là il ya quand même une mise
sur la sellette de parlementaires ces
mesures pour voler sa belle pour demain
pour de mauvaises après soit on aimerait
surtout pour des mesures que ni le
gouvernement ni le même
gouvernement ni le président de la
république ne s'appliquent à eux mêmes
d'accord donc vous approuver ces mesures
sur le fond mais vous dites ça participe
quand même d'un affaiblissement du
parlement et ça use
la faute revient l'exécutif pour la
transparence l'explication je suis pour
tout cela je dis simplement que d'abord
il ya des limites à la transparence
comme dans tout métier comme dans tout
métier
évidemment garder non pas une part
nombre mais garder une part de
confidentialité
et puis à ce moment là je pense que le
gouvernement aussi beaucoup de progrès à
faire
d'accord vous pouvez leur faire des
suggestions le demande le centralisme
vous avez des propositions
éventuellement sur ce sujet la suite de
l'épreuve de vérité tout de suite avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
bonsoir jean françaix saint soir michel
bonsoir eric woerth alors est-ce que
emmanuel macron n'est pas en train de
sortir l'économie française de l'ornière
alors l'économie française elle en sort
enfin en sort sans emmanuel macron j'ai
calé dans un rythme d'évolution qui fait
que l on commence à être à peu près dans
le peloton
dans le peloton des économies
européennes et des économies de l'oscd
eux ça a mis du temps on a pris beaucoup
de temps pour ça mais que ce soit
emmanuel macron quelqu'un d'autre à la
présidence de la république le taux de
croissance de la france aujourd'hui dans
deux ans trois ans un autre sujet mais
aujourd'hui serait exactement le même
il y est pour rien je pense réellement
qu'il n'est pas là pour irriguer tout
n'est pour rien dans ce temps-là sens je
pense qu'ils viennent que le moral des
affaires le le fait que les
entrepreneurs en france où apprendre par
exemple chiffres de novembre ce qu'on
appelle le climat des affaires en france
ce chiffre est le plus élevé depuis 2008
on sent quand même qu'il ya quelque
chose qui se passe dans ce pays
il vous vous pensez qu'il n'y est pour
rien et j'essayais de regarder
objectivement les choses qui peut penser
qu'un président qui est là depuis six
mois ils soient pour quelque chose aux
1,7 ou 1,8 qu'on fera en termes de taux
de croissance
absolument personne l'autre sujet c'est
l'ambiance dans le pays
ambiance dans le pays elle est
évidemment bien meilleur que sous
françois hollande ça pouvait pas être
pire
pour tout vous dire et je crois que
c'est la poule et l'oeuf que le taux de
croissance je rappelle qu'on est quand
même encore un peu en dessous du taux de
croissance moyen de l'union européenne
mais on est un taux de croissance
aujourd'hui qui nous permet de financer
des choses qu'on pouvait plus financé
par ailleurs je rappelle quand même que
ce taux de croissance c'est celui là qui
remplit les carnets de commandes des
entreprises et que le chef d'entreprise
ou les milieux économiques
évidemment leur moral varie en fonction
de leurs carnets de commandes
donc tout ça c'est la poule et l'oeuf et
puis il ya des mesures emblématiques et
je ne sous estime pas la capacité du
président à représenter une france à
l'étranger qui est bien représentée et
puis aussi à donner envie à celles et
ceux qui ont envie d'investir je les
actes sont parfois un peu différent on
peut rentrer dans le détail on va le
faire j'ai deux nient pas la capacité de
conviction ou d'attraction ou de
communication du président de la
république je ne nie pas non plus sa
volonté de réforme tout mais je dis tout
président de la république aujourd'hui
serait dans un système de réforme
approfondie parce que c'est le temps est
venu pour cela après la crise
dix ans après la crise le temps est venu
pour ça des réformes approfondies
dites-vous après celle du précédent
quinquennat en quelque sorte d'écouter
ce que dit michel sapin c'était ce matin
sur public sénat il reconnaît démérité
on va voir si vous aller aussi loin que
lui qui aurait t'il de malki aurait-il
de préjudiciable pour le président
d'aujourd'hui pas dire que par exemple
la situation économique de cette année
je ne parle pas d'eux dans un an ou dans
deux ans elle est dû à quoi à des
décisions en particulier prises par son
prédécesseur il peut le dire d'autant
plus qu'ils aient comme il était
ministre de l'économie
il a participé à ces décisions qu'il a
été un principal conseiller du président
de la république précédents et donc il a
participé à ces décisions
je pourrais prendre toute une série
d'exemples la formation professionnelle
aujourd'hui elle va être réformé c'est
très bien il faut l'approfondir et
approfondir quoi la réforme qui avaient
été menées précédemment
oui il ya un héritage toute façon tout
ça est une continuité donc et un
héritage elle a posé aux langes n'a pas
fait que des choses négatives le cic et
la baisse des charges patronales années
de la compétitivité au pays même si ça
peut être très bien fait vous devez
julien il ya le sait exactement un an
vous vous aviez cette phrase mais moi
novembre 2016 françois hollande casse la
france il est temps des incas c'est la
france et moi développer une minute
parce que sinon le cic eux étaient une
bonne mesure le pack de responsabilité
doit toujours considéré qu'une bonne
russe trop compliqué
il yad'autres d'autres sont là dessus
mais c'était une bonne mesure parce que
la nôtre côté françois hollande il a
jamais été vraiment président de la
république
la vérité c'est ça dans le coeur des
français et que beaucoup de mesures ont
été des mesures dont on a mis beaucoup
de temps à s'en remettre
l'augmentation massive de la fiscalité
des ménages et des entreprises
rien sur le code du travail la loi elle
comme riz a été un échec et une reculade
le fait casser la gauche lui a rendu
impossible d'avoir une majorité au
parlement fin bref tout ça a conduit à
des à une situation inextricable
mais la croissance qui est aujourd'hui à
la croissance française est une
croissance dont les manuels mâcon d'une
certaine manière est rythmée sait d'où
il vient du monde entier
non mais elle vient d'où elle vient du
monde entier parce que monsieur c'est
pareil là il ya quand même oublié aussi
toutes les erreurs qui ont été commises
et dieu sait qu'elles ont été
extraordinairement nombreuses et dans
cette erreur là il ya le fait que la
france elle a été en retard de
croissance pendant toutes les années
hollande jusque l'année dernière
jusqu'en 2017
jusque jusque 7 cette année donc voilà
aujourd'hui on est juste dans une
croissance de rattrapage aujourd'hui la
france est là le taux de croissance
qu'elle aurait dû avoir il ya deux ou
trois ans bon ben alors on a deux ou
trois ans de retard probablement à cause
des mesures de france 90 sur la
politique économique elle même vous la
jugez com - sk pas quand même une
réorientation des politiques vers les
entreprises par exemple par la baisse du
taux de l'impôt sur les sociétés par
l'ins par la suppression de l'impôt sur
la fortune
je voudrais m'extraire de la doxa la
doxa classique là dessus je pense que
non et j'essaie de le dire et de le
prouver parce que je le regrette
on est dans une phase de croissance donc
c'est plus facile tellement plus facile
de réformer avec 2% de croissance
qu'avec moins de 2% de croissance et le
paysage il totalement totalement
différent donc on est dans un moment de
facilité pour la réforme qu'il faut
l'utiliser à plein et dans le domaine
des dépenses et des finances publiques
on a des dépenses publiques qui continue
à augmenter plus vite que l'inflation
on a des on a
déficit public de l'état qui a jamais
été aussi important sur les six ou sept
dernières années quand même il faut il
faut le dire et le gouvernement n'a pas
décidé de faire de l'entreprise une
priorité pourquoi laisser les fêtes
quand on transforme est vrai un peu
technique malheureusement mais quand on
pense que oui oui mais c'est la réalité
des choses la baisse de forme
c'est d'abord ans forment le crédit
d'impôt en baisse des charges
on oublie au passage on oublie au
passage 3 2 milliards d'euros que les
entreprises paieront donc c'est une
augmentation du coût du travail
quand sur l'impôt sur les sociétés le
gouvernement affiche sa volonté de
baisser l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est
en réalité une mesure de françois
hollande qu'il avait déjà fait voter cc
puis mesure de françois hollande le
gouvernement confiant la mesure de
françois hollande la prend pour lui-même
et la prolonge mais dans le même temps
il augmente l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme on l'a jamais augmenté en quinze
jours pour financer une une mesure de la
taxation des dividendes -une mesure
annule et de fiscalité par le conseil
constitutionnel et le gouvernement se
trouve en face de cela plutôt que de
financer par des économies ils
augmentent massivement il augmente de
15% ou de 30% selon le niveau de chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises l'impôt sur
les sociétés payé par elle-même au mois
de décembre
donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas en
réalité c'est moins bien que hollande
dans le domaine c'est comme ça c'est
alors la conjoncture est meilleure tout
est donc beaucoup plus facile mais c'est
moins bien que landes le sait c'est une
augmentation des charges patronales ou
des charges des employeurs par rapport à
françois hollande et l'augmentation de
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui en
résultera n'est pas neutralisé dans
l'est dans les comptes françois hollande
a été plus bénéfique pour l'économie
française qu emmanuel macron et la
suppression de la vie entre nous
derrière l' isf on est favorable à la
suppression de l'sf sauf qu'ils le
suppriment qu'en partie il crée un impôt
sur la fortune immobilière et dans cet
impôt il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qu'ils paieront à titre
professionnel d'accord de match c'est
pire que hollande c'est ça ce que vous
êtes en train de dire je sais pas si
c'est pire l'économie française je
considère qu'aujourd'hui
le gouvernement des manuels mâcon n'a
pas montré sa volonté de mettre en avant
la compétitivité du pays dans les
discours de sur les estrades
la france est une start up tout ça tout
ça c'est bel et beau mais c'est passé
pas ce qui se passe dans le financement
des entreprises en financement des
entreprises avant l'usf pme concourait à
7 ou 800 millions d'euros de financement
des petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est plus carrée +10 sf on supprime la
niche fiscale peut-être fallait-il
supprimer le dispositif mais il fallait
au moins le remplacer pendant quelques
quelques années les propositions faites
par la majorité sont des propositions
extrêmement étroites allées au-delà des
2,5 smic dans la baisse des charges
patronales si le rapport aux gallois
donc voyez c'était pas noté le rapport
aux gallois nous on considère que
c'était effectivement quelque chose
d'important parce que c'est les salaires
de l'industrie et l'industrie française
est celle qui est exposé à la
concurrence
il ya un refus absolu de dépasser les
2,5 etc etc
à propos des 3% les 306 voir via un
sondage vous êtes dans cette émission
incidents de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée nationale
est ce que vous êtes on passe aux
sondages tout cela je me présente parce
que c'est la première question est ce
indispensable que la france serait
réduisent donc dès cette année son
déficit pour passer sous la fameuse
barre des 3% voilà la question posée la
réponse
écoutez il ya une grande majorité de oui
des français sont convaincus à 72% 27%
disent non votre question jean francis
que ce sera le cas c est ce que vous
êtes assurés que fin 2010 est déjà la
france passera sous les 3 % compte tenu
de la petite incertitude sur les
recettes sur la validation de la taxe du
dividende autres moi je ne suis pas chez
eurostat donc c'est plutôt le niveau
européen qui va calculer tout ça je n'en
sais rien on voit bien que cette taxe
c'est ce collectif budgétaire de l'ue
méreau 1 sur la sur le remplacement de
la taxe et 3%
il a créé beaucoup de beaucoup de
confusion je crois que c'était une très
mauvaise idée de faire une tragédie là
dessus pour essayer de montrer que le
gouvernement faisait beaucoup mieux que
ce que ce qu'avait fait le précédent ça
c'est sûr mais enfin est-ce qu'on avait
besoin d'une telle tragédie
mais je ne le crois pas et je pense
surtout qu'on n'avait pas besoin d'une
telle solution parce que d'une solution
qui crée une incertitude incroyable ça
veut dire dès qu'il ya un problème en
france on met un maximum de fiscalité
bon est ce qu'on sera à 3 ou pas à 3 c
eurostat qui le dira moi je crois qu'il
faut tout cas il faut continuer cet
effort qui est un qui est faible en
france est aujourd'hui faible était
faible soit hollande et continue à être
faible sous mac rond il faut absolument
maîtriser la dépense publique la réponse
n'est pas dans l'augmentation de la
fiscalité
on est dix ans après la crise est une
crise majeure aujourd'hui la france ne
doit retrouver un rythme d'évolution de
la dépense qui soit très inférieur est
fondée sur des réformes de structure
quoi pas sur la conjoncture
et quand on regarde ce que dit l'union
européenne on s'aperçoit que les
quelques efforts qui sont faits
l'amélioration du solde budgétaire s'est
dit la crise essentiellement due à du
conjoncturel est pas du structurel et si
nous faisons les efforts structurels que
demande la commission alors on serait on
serait un déficit bien
mais qu'est ce que vous préconisez vous
c'est de relancer les suppressions
d'emplois dans la fonction publique par
exemple c'est on serait si si si
réellement le gouvernement s'il n'y
avait pas ce déficit
s'ils avaient un niveau déficit
structurel qui était contenu qu'ils
étaient moins contenue ronceray à 3 3%
déficit donc c'est un peu comme ça que
la commission condenser le conjoncturel
qui permet d'aller en dessous des 3 et
sur les trois ans qui viennent on flirte
avec les 3 on est à 2 9 de 8,3 en 2010
neuf donc on flirte avec tout ça ça
nécessite des réformes de fond mais des
dépenses publiques par exemple la
réforme des retraites
elle doit continuer c'est la première
dépense publique nous on l'a fait
toujours on a toujours affronté même si
ça va mieux olivier mais c'est minime ça
va vous savez réforme est annoncée à
mieux parce que l'on mesure tout ou tous
les mois on change d'idée là dessus du
zéro systémiques et non systémiques ça
ne veut rien dire mais strictement rien
dire la réforme va changer l'âge de la
retraite et le passé à 60 ans et est
systémique parce que ça cas c'est un
tabou qui était la réforme qui était la
retraite à 60 ans les réformes par
points c'est très important il faut mais
c'est pas ça qui permet de financer les
retraites qui permet de financer les
retraites c'est de savoir combien on
touche au fond à quel âge on le touche
et quel est le niveau de cotisation que
ce soit que ce soit des points ou pas
des points il faut qu'ils aient d'une
cotisation en tout cas des prestations
sociales qu'ils soient maîtrisés et qui
souhaitent unique et pas uniquement à
bout je fais un peu d'apl lord majdi aux
bailleurs sociaux qui doivent rembourser
l'apl et puis j'appelle à une grande loi
qui viendra plus tard et la maîtrise des
effectifs de la fonction publique il ya
324 fonctionnaires de moins sur les
ministères en 2018 en fondamentalement
où est la grande ambition j'en sais rien
à ce moment par les petits projets c'est
pas des petites ambitions
même avec une forte communication et
même avec une communication ambitieuse
qui vont permettre à la france de
réformer et c'est le moment
très rapidement la cour des comptes a
publié un rapport assez sévère sur la
médecine libérale en prenant des mesures
coercitives à ce que la cour des comptes
est bien dans son rôle est ce que d'un
mot est ce que vous êtes à que je ne
partage pas ce que dit la cour des
comptes sur leur une sur la liberté par
exemple d'installation et je pense que
c'est l'extrême iliad il ya des points
qui sont extrêmement importants donc et
on doit les respecter parce que ça fonde
le système où notre pacte social
maintenant que la cour des comptes
dans son rôle pour essayer de faire
avancer les choses et dire on peut pas
vivre des déficits d'assurance maladie
aussi important parce que ça mettra en
cause la qualité des soins à venir elle
est évidemment dans son rôle merci
beaucoup jean francis se maintenant
c'est nadège peljak de l' agence france
presse qui nous rejoint pour la deuxième
partie de l'émission bonjour bonsoir
nadège bonsoir bonsoir
alors question ma question alors dans
dix jours votre parti va élire un
nouveau président vous êtes toujours
pour monsieur wauquiez
oui bon c'est lui qui va gagner parce
que tous les cas c'est le favori
écoutez on s'est toujours trompée dans
les pronostics donc je serai prudent
espoirs bon mais si par hasard il
n'était pas élu dès le premier tour
c'est à dire le 10 décembre face à deux
candidats qui sont encore moins connus -
cap et que lui et messieurs madame
portelli et monsieur de calan maël de
calan est ce que ça serait une forme
d'échec
oulala non vous d'abord avec des si j'en
sais rien moi ce qui compte c'est que
les républicains se dote d'un président
et le celui qui aura gagné en tout cas
je milite pour que ce soit laurent
wauquiez il y sera président à plein des
républicains après une étape l'un des
républicains ça veut dire que vous ne
veut pas laisser de côté donc il a donc
tous les autres quoi ils avocats de la
vocation à ressembler sera président de
tout le monde et chacun doit faire des
efforts lui même parce qu'il est
président des républicains donc il aura
un rôle de rassemblement qui est
absolument des efforts sur lui-même test
d'effort sur lui même il doit il doit
rassurer non non un effort président des
républicains tous les présidents et doit
faire des efforts de rassemblement mais
tous ceux aussi qui sont à l'intérieur
des républicains et qui est critique
laurent wauquiez est ou qui veulent
incarner autre chose une autre ligne
comme on dit aujourd'hui dans le langage
politique et bien eux aussi doivent
faire des efforts pour aider le
président des républicains et son équipe
à réussir
il ya des déclarations sûrement qu'ils
n'ont pas l'air de beaucoup aidé et je
pense madame pécresse qui dit par
exemple
bon bah on va voir si ça s extremis de
trop je verrai ce que je ferai à
l'avenir
je crois que monsieur xavier bertrand
est un petit peu sur la même ligne mais
aussi et je trouve qu'on parle trop de
politique
ces sujets sains fait normal s'en
servaient pour tous les réflexions du
patron de l heure j'attends maintenant
j'ai du mal à m'intéresser à ça je pense
que les républicains ont besoin d'un
président si d'autres souhaité l'être ou
contester la ligne de laurent wauquiez
il fallait qu'il soit candidat ne l'ont
pas été donc je crois qu'il faut que les
républicains demeurent et perdure on a
besoin d'une grande force
d'interposition au fond entre le
gouvernement monsieur macron et les
extrêmes
monsieur macron adore parler avec les
extrêmes avec l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite c'est une manière pour
lui de n'exister tout seul on a besoin
dans le champ républicain dans le champ
le vrai champ de la démocratie on a
besoin d'une opposition est en tout cas
d'une force d'alternance si aucune
alternance possible monsieur cran et
qu'il échoue je le souhaite pas bon je
souhaite que la france à leur
réussissent mais s'il échoue il ya
toujours dans un pays une alternance
possible et aujourd'hui les républicains
sont en convalescence après cette année
un terrible qui a été un pur
pour nous 2010 est donc nous avons
besoin de représenter cette force
d'alternance et on a pas besoin
immédiatement d'avoir des oppositions au
sein même de notre propre formation
besoin la reconstruire donc il faut la
reconstruire
et puis si ça se passe pas bien là bas
on verra on en fera le bilan
et bien moi je peux sol paraît que ça va
bien se passer est qu'on va redevenir
une force d'alternance qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui totalement et quand
j'entends bien ce que vous dites mais je
me permets d'insister parce que c'est
vrai pendant beaucoup de critiques
contre monsieur wauquiez alors gérald
darmanin voulait me dire gérald darmanin
il est du ministre il est devenu
ministre de monsieur macron et puis
maintenant même il fait partie du parti
il attire aussi les disqualifier enfin
lui aussi dit qu'avec ma avec wauquiez
c'est quand même l'extréme nation de la
droite qui se prépare on entend quand
même beaucoup ça même dans votre parti
alors à votre avis pourquoi est ce que
monsieur wauquiez suscite autant de bien
sûr les gatti selon mediaset laurent
wauquiez il a une
argile et aussi clivant il dit noir
blanc et les clients donc certains
peuvent ne pas se reconnaître dans ça et
pour rassembler c'est pas évident les
clients non mais pour faire ensemble
pour faire exister l'opposition c'est
peut-être nécessaire c'est peut-être
nécessaire est-ce qu'il se devait
aujourd'hui toujours son ambiguïté au
soir du premier tome non il y avait
dedans je crois pas et je crois que
c'est un mauvais procès qui a été fait
alors invoqué est ado il se poursuit ce
port faut sauver par exemple quelqu'un
qui était exclu de votre parti c'est
franck riester qui dit encore ce matin
on se dirige tout droit vers une
alliance en tous les cas d'idées avec le
front national vous vous dites vous
voulez incarné l'opposition dans le
champ républicain je pense à pour une
insulte voilà je vais n'a su que je
pense qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire ça
d'abord ils ont été membre d'un
républicain pendant longtemps ils ont
demandé l'investiture des républicains
pendant longtemps ils ont sauté dans les
organes directeurs des républicains à
l'époque on faisait le ni ni
voilà ça a été pour un certain nombre la
ligne de position pendant l'élection
le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle n'a pas été la mienne moi
j'ai voté manuel macro deuxième tour
donc je me sens absolument libre pour
dire que ceux qui ont fait un autre
choix qui nous font de ne pas aller
voter
c'était un choix qu'ils ont exercé en
toute liberté et qui doivent pas le
porter en tout cas communes comme une
croix et je pense que ceux qui sont
rentrés au gouvernement il avait besoin
d'un certain nombre d'alibi ou prétexte
pour entrer au gouvernement que c'était
un prétexte assez facile me semble-t-il
vous propose d'écouter l'une des
personnalités qu'on n'a pas encore citer
jusqu'à présent c'est alain juppé qui
est venu rendre visite bien aux
sénateurs traitement non plus monsieur
la très tendre avec le rand réécrire en
tous les cas et quand il parle devant
les micros il est assez concis écoutez
bien ce qu'il dit sur sa position à lui
est toujours construire moi je ne suis
pas quelqu'un de destructeur et revoit
alors voilà donc ça c'est quand même n'a
rien dans le jardin de la révoquer la
raison je pense qu'il vise celles et
ceux qui vont
ça te rejoins le gouvernement mais il a
raison il faut être constructeur est une
et nous le sommes
personne d'autre ne dis comme ça
ce sucre il est avec les sénateurs pro
macron un messie alors c'est bien choix
des républiques le choix des
républicains c'est d'aider les réformes
quand on considère que ce sont des
bonnes réformes pour le pays notamment
lorsqu'elle se donne à notre propre
projet mais quand même on va rester un
peu cohérent on nous avons voté hier
hier ou avant-hier nous avons voté pour
les ordonnances c'est pas une opposition
constructive et je retire le mot
d'ailleurs qui n'existe plus puisque les
constructif
même le sigle politique a éclaté en
mille morceaux entre je rejoins en
marche je crée un petit parti ou trois
je sais pas où je bon franchement moi je
pense qu'il ya un pôle solide sérieux
ancrée sur les territoires dans les
territoires et des élus locaux
nous avons un pot le solide et sérieux
qui s'appelle les républicains qui a ses
racines dans l'histoire de notre pays
eh bien il faut le faire vivre le faire
revivre
refonder nos peut-être nos valeurs
réellement le dire concrètement
travailler sur des projets à transférer
nos valeurs vous pouvez nous parler de
ses valeurs mais parce que souvent on
parle des valeurs on dit pas lesquels on
a besoin on a besoin nouveau d'y
réfléchir et je pense que notamment il
ya une grosse différence entre une
société où on met en avant la
responsabilité individuelle et on met la
responsabilité collective plutôt en
avant c'est pas le même type de société
c'est pas dire que c'est des sociétés
qui ne sont pas solidaires il ya
toujours beaucoup de solidarité en
france mais ça veut dire aussi un moment
donné qu'on croit plus à l'individu
qu'au quai la responsabilité collective
chaque individu porte aussi les réseaux
ou de son échec bien sûr que non mais si
jamais totalement séparés mais ça
oriente des politiques publiques croire
au travail ou moins au travail croyait
encore à l'effort au moins à l'effort
dans tout ça n'a tout ça est très
différent l'ouverture ou pas au monde
l'ouverture ou pas le rock donc l europe
ça aussi c'est l'europe puisque on va en
parler
autant de sujets essentiels sur lesquels
les républicains doivent au fur et à
mesure à nouveau se repositionner
pourquoi pas inventer une autre manière
de faire de la politique la politique
qui est faite aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement
c'est la politique du cynisme la police
et c'est une once izarra franchement
c'est parfois la politique du 19e siècle
la rapport de force la décision qui
tombe en cascade jusque dans les groupes
parlementaires et bien au delà
et puis des ministres extrêmement
technique alors c'est bien il faut
évidemment connaître les sujets c'est
mieux quand même mais qui n'ont pas de
vision politique sinon seuls de soutenir
uniquement il sans concession le
président a rappelé que les chacun
procès du président la réplique tous les
mythes ou les des députés et sénateurs
mais tous les députés qui ont été élus
en marche ont pour la plupart procédé du
président de la république hier j'en
suis aussi lié à papier comme quoi ils
n'avaient pas droit de voter donc on
s'arrête tout ça c'était les amants de
sens et j'essaie à 30 ans 40 ans enfin
c'était ça a été je pense qu'au
contraire je crois que l'économie doit
être une économie collaborative
mais en tout cas il n'y a pas de
politique collaborative au sein de leurs
marges alors vous reconnaissez que deux
parties aient l'air et convalescence
était le thème de notre deuxième
question du sondage opinionway pour
cette émission
alors voilà la question diriez vous que
le parti ait l'air vit une crise durable
les français sont 60 2% à dire oui notez
que chez les sympathisants de droite ce
chiffrement tout de même à 48% une crise
passagère 26% pour 10 % des français
alors cela m'avait pas les convaincre
puisqu'il considère que vous n'êtes pas
en crise mais quand même il ya du boulot
c'est une bonne base mais c'est que
c'est vrai enfin moi je serai français
je répondrais je pense que je répondrais
d'ailleurs je crois pas je crois jamais
à la durabilité est ce qu'un politique
durable c'est à peu près c'est à peu
près sur quatre ou cinq jours quoi et
puis après tout tout ça change le je
pense qu'on va faire un vrai travail de
fond qui aura un président que ce
président il faut l'aider à réussir si
j'aimais in si jamais ça ne marche pas
on en tirera des conséquences mais il
n'y a aucune raison de considérer que ça
n'a pas marché et je suis pas d'accord
pour considérer qu'il faut dès
maintenant
finalement incarner une opposition à
laurent wauquiez c'est au fond ce que
souhaite un certain nombre quand ils
prennent la parole et bien ils ont tort
ils doivent pas apparaître comme une
opposition alors dans leur propre parti
doivent aider leurs propres partis à
réussir à rassembler à couvrir
l'ensemble du champ de la droite du
centre droit jusqu à la droite classique
et puis essayer de contribuer à la
création d'une nouvelle force
d'alternance qui va s'appeler les
répugnants
on parlait d' élargir le parti ou de
rassembler il parraine vous allez nous
dire peut-être que vous savez que
monsieur wauquiez aurait près aurait
proposé la présidence du conseil
national à valérie pécresse s'il est élu
c'est peut-être jeu pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs ce serait très bien mais je
jouais pas je ne le sais pas une ne peux
m'en prendre à valérie pécresse quand on
invitera voilà ce que vous même vous
guetter les signes d'ouverture vous ne
l'avez dit moi je suis une ouverture je
souhaite c'est pas il n'y a pas de fin
de toute façon on réussira pas dans la
fermeture donc il faut il faut ouvrir
mais c'était déjà le cas à l'ump d'alain
juppé et c'était une bonne chose mais
c'était compliqué à créer un donc l'ump
d'alain juppé s'était justement de
représenter l'ensemble de la droite
française et les républicains ont
vocation à cela et le président des
républicains a évidemment vocation à
cela
merci nadège troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
michaël szames sd public sénat qui nous
rejoint par michaëlle jean michel
roussin vous avez un peu répondu à mes
questions mais je vais vouloir opposer à
nouveau ce que vous pensez de la
politique menée par emmanuel macron on
l'appelle certains l'appellent le
nouveau monde vous l'avais appelé la
politique du 19e siècle
prenons peut-être un exemple assez
concret le retour des élections à des
listes nationales
c'est quoi les politiques ou nouveau
monde
on voit bien que le vous le gouvernement
essayait de mettre en avant les
élections européennes parce qu'elles
sont faciles plutôt les choses que des
élections
look avec le débat à droite sur l'europe
a toujours été un débat historique entre
secrets grievances d'europe ceux qui
veulent moins de rhodes celles qui
veulent plusieurs sacs serait qu'ils en
veulent pas bosser mes photos modifiées
oui et puis il n'ya pas d'implantation
territoriale du parti en marche donc
plus et que la représentation dans
marché évidemment emmanuel macron qu'à
la fois le président marchés le
président de le président de la
république donc et bien en même temps il
est secrétaire de circonscription dans
chacune des circonscriptions
donc il a plutôt intérêt lui en tant que
représentants politiques il a plutôt
intérêt à avoir une liste nationale qui
se centralise sur lui même que des
listes régionales centralisé sur
d'autres personnalités
donc il faut faire attention à tout ça
et on ne doit changer les modes de
scrutin avec avec beaucoup beaucoup de
de prudence pourquoi parce que changer
un mode de scrutin c'est par principe
trifouiller dans des élections
critiquées
oui trifouiller dans des élections donc
il ya des français en général n'aiment
pas ça en tout cas faut vraiment
expliquer que c'est nécessaire les
grandes régions alors c'est vrai que les
grandes régions éloignées à ce moment là
des élus mais c'est vrai pour les
conseillers régionaux aussi entre nous
donc les grandes régions peuvent être
porteuses me semble-t-il de liste de
listes européennes ça permet aussi de
faire émerger d'autres d'autres d'autres
personnalités qu'on va chercher dans les
régions plutôt que chercher sur le plan
sur le plan sur le plan national et par
exemple aussi si on parlait d'europe
avant de passer à une autre question
ça permet aussi d'avoir deux camps les
mondialistes contre les souverainistes
donc de faire quelque part emmanuel
macron contre marine le pen ou jean luc
mélenchon et vous là dedans vous
n'existez plus mais on nous promet
toujours des lendemains absolument
épouvantable quoi républicain ça explose
et ça marche pas l'enjeu qui on les aime
pas enfin j'ai tout ça tout ça comme ça
mais on voit on voit se dessiner
oui je crois que c'est le moment et
complexes on a un gouvernement tout seul
qui occupent 90 % de la scène qui
dit qu'il va réformer chaque jour un
sujet différent
nous nous sommes en train nous n'avons
pas le même tempo c'est normal
l'opposition ne peut pas avoir le même
thème pour n'a besoin de reconstruire
quelque chose de solide ça prend du
temps on est plutôt en train de faire
les plans de la maison quand remettre la
première pierre est la première pierre
elle sera mise au moment de l'élection
du président des républicains à
l'assemblée comme au sénat on incarne
une forme d'opposition jeu j'espère en
tout cas responsables et intelligentes
ont essayé de le faire en tout cas mais
on n'a pas besoin de s'excuser
tous les trois jours de d'être dans
l'opposition dans une démocratie on doit
être fier dans l'opposition au
gouvernement doit écouter l'opposition
entre nous d'ailleurs être constructive
puisque c'était le terme qui étaient
employés au moment des élections ça va
dans les deux sens vous pouvez dans
l'opposition être constructive vis-à-vis
du gouvernement
il faut aussi que le gouvernement soit
constructive vis-à-vis de l'opposition
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas la plupart
des amendements présentés par les
membres de l'opposition ne sont ne sont
jamais retenu voir écouter
lorsqu'on réforme position c'est le mot
qu'on emploie souvent vous les gars
qu'on réforme le code du travail
on demande aux syndicats ce qui est bien
naturel on est dans le champ social on
peut peut-être aussi demandé à
l'opposition
lorsqu'on veut réformer les retraites il
faut à ce moment là évidemment entendre
les partis politiques et sur ce qu'ils
ont à dire je les fais en 2010 j'ai pas
attendu d'en faire un système politique
ou de communication je reprends votre
expression très tout y est peut-être
d'un mot bien politique ou nouveau monde
encore une fois quand on envisage
notamment de recouper les élections
locales municipales et autres pour au
lieu de 2020 2021
c'est quoi pour le gouvernement veut pas
il faut regarder enfin une hypothèse que
des arrière pensées
il n'y a pas de pensée même temps ce ne
sont que des arrière pensées
donc le gouvernement il doit se demander
comment au mieux aborder pour lui même
ces élections et doit se dire que les
regrouper c'est plus facile
en même temps ça donne ça retire du
quand vous votez pour plusieurs
personnes au niveau départemental
municipal europe et enfin tout ça vous
mélangez tout ça vous savez plus très
bien pour qui vous votez quoi il y aura
autant du on avait quasiment que de
l'électeur que des lecteurs à ce moment
là celui qui est le plus en avant c'est
évidemment le président de la république
puisque on va te très très largement je
pense que tout est fait pour repousser
pour essayer d'avoir des effets cette
croissance est le monde donc il y aura
évidemment des effets j'espère que les
réformes mises en oeuvre de parfois avec
notre soutien sont des réformes qui
permettront la france
dans le bon sens et notamment de réduire
le chômage même si la croissance pour
l'instant d'une croissance sans son
ensemble sont vraiment créations
d'emploi nettes suffisante
on voit bien que c'est tout ça est fait
pour le gouvernement pour exister mais
c'est pour ça que il faut faire
attention à tout cela et c'est pour ça
aussi que c'est pas y'a pas de nouveau
monde c'est faux vous signez un nouveau
monde parfois il est pire que l'ancien
donc attention au nouveau monde
il n'y a pas des gens qui sont dans le
nouveau monde et des gens qui seraient
dans l'ordre dans l'ancien monde
y'a pas des français qui n'ont plus le
droit de cité en france parce qu'il
serait dans l'ancien monde
il n'y a pas des observateurs et de
l'autre des acteurs c'est pas comme ça
la france n'est pas une entreprise
la france n a pas d actionnaires elle a
des citoyens c'est extrêmement
différents et qu'on est 99 ans ou
comment on comptait six mois et on est
français
alors on y participe en fonction de son
âge en fonction de sa capacité mais en
même temps il n'ya pas des anciens et
des nouveaux ça c'est de chaque fois que
ça a été fait impression que vous avez
l'impression de dire pas pratique les
clients une date leur disons moitié des
français le nouveau monde comme elle
aime dire elle est puisqu'il aime le
dire tout le temps les représentants
dans marche c'est humiliant pour la
france et pour les français
nous sommes tous français on a tous une
responsabilité dans l'avenir de notre
pays que les chevaliers retardé par des
français pratiquent politique les
pratiques politiques dans marchon des
pratiques politiques de tous les partis
politiques depuis bien longtemps
enfin quand on dit attention les vieux
partis les nouveaux partis enfin les
nouveaux partis sont appelés à devenir
vieux et très vite ils prennent les
réflexes ni mauvais réflexe de nombre de
vieux parti vraiment enfin je regardais
comment les choses se passent majorité
qui est totalement caporaliser notre nom
verdier effectivement et c'est la vérité
ces chaleurs et vérité mais quand
emmanuel macron va en afrique pour
tourner le dos à la françafrique est ce
qu'il ne fait pas entrer là le pays dans
un nouveau monde
tous les présidents sont allés en
afrique pour tourner le dos à la
françafrique
enfin j'ai pour l'instant prenez les
dites tout chaque président la
république est allé en afrique faire un
grand un grand discours en avril alors
je pense à nicolas sarkozy en 2007 à
dakar et probablement aller trop loin il
a probablement employé des formules
je malheureuse que je ne m'aimais mais
il y est allé en tout cas pour ici et
dire des choses emmanuel macron il va
pour essayer dire un certain nombre des
choses et se termine par cette affaire
de climatisation ah bon on va regarder
puisque vous en parlez on va regarder on
va se
remémorer cette scène qui a beaucoup
marqué et évidemment effectivement
puisque devant les étudiants donc d'où
il était interpellé sur la climatisation
sur l'électricité et voilà ce qu a donc
répondu le président français en
ajoutant une note d'humour
interrogez vous sur le sous-jacent
psychologique qui a derrière votre
interpellation et l' enthousiasme que ça
a créé c'est quelque part vous me parlez
comme si j'étais toujours une puissance
coloniale mais moi je ne veux pas
m'occuper de l'électricité dans les
universités
c'est le travail c'est le travail du
président
alors par contre alors par contre je
vous rassure
découle sans voix reste là
du coup il partirait réparer la
climatisation
moi je connais si l'ambiance 1 j'ai été
dans des réunions de 7,7 nature une
ambiance souvent c'est extraordinaire
mais c'est quand même les propos du
président de la république c'est pas le
propos d'un ministre ou d'un même d'un
premier ministre faut faire attention à
ce qu'on dit je pas sûr que les manuels
mâcon loreidy ailleurs qu'en afrique
quoi et je suis pas sûr que donc ça
rompt pas avec ça représente de
mauvaises habitudes les européens je
suis pas sûr qu'il aurait parlé à notre
dirigeant de la même manière donc je
pense qu'on peut toujours dire que c'est
d'humour tu sais très bien l'humour
c'est je suis pas contre enfin il ya un
côté exalté dans ce discours il ya un
côté très exalté être avec curieux
d'abord la vie dure 2 heures 45
on se croit revenu alors là dans autant
d des leaders qui est ce m 3 heure de
discours
donc bon je vois rien de bien nouveau
jouer au contraire des réminiscences qui
ne sont pas les bonnes réminiscences je
crois que l'afrique il faut traiter l
afrique de l est à dire un pays ou un
continent comme un autre avec
probablement un potentiel de
développement plus important qu'un autre
des difficultés aussi sans doute plus
importante que pour d'autres continents
c'est un énorme partenariat qu'il faut
fonder avec la france avec des pays qui
sont de nature extrêmement différente il
faut les aider à régler les problèmes de
violence et en même temps les africains
peuvent aussi nous aider parfois s'ils
ont des choses aussi à nous dire c'est
équilibré
si on parle de principe d'un
déséquilibré je sens tout ça là dedans
ça ne va pas et la jeunesse africaine l
attend pas ce type de ce type de
discours me semble-t-il
je vous parlais d'un autre président il
ya un an presque jour pour jour france a
renoncé à se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle il dit comme ça et qu'il
ne s'interdit pas de s'intéresse à la
vie politique
est ce que vous le voyez vous un avenir
politique à aucun aucun aucun enfin je
connais sarkozy est revenu
françois hollande ne pourrait pas
revenir enfin bon nicolas sarkozy n'a
malheureusement je penche
pour le pays était n'a pas réussi à
passer le premier tour de l'élection
primaire je vais mais nicolas sarkozy et
enfin été candidat deux fois gagné a
perdu de peu a été a été président d'une
france en pleine tourmente
enfin la crise étaient colossaux s'il a
même connu une crise de 2013
ouais ouais c'est une crise du tct les
sous jacents comme dirait le président
de la république d'aujourd'hui c'était
les sous-jacents de la grande crise de
2008-2009 donc c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
a affronté les paquets de mer les plus
importants enfin - 2 % de croissance
comme à -2% dressé récession la france
en reste et sur le monde entier en
récession des banques qui fermait dans
tout ça donc il ne pourrait pas revenir
françois hollande n'a jamais vécu n'a
jamais vécu ça donc non je ne crois pas
je ne le crois pas et il a été empêché
de se présenter pour des raisons on peut
en faire et beaucoup d'exégèse met donc
et pas de raison particulière
la page me semble-t-il est tournée et
soufre dit que nicolas sarkozy est assez
impressionné quand même un par emmanuel
macron et vous vous le voyez toujours
nicolas sarkozy il m'arrive vous en
parlez 3 et wii n'est sans doute plus
élogieux que vous sur ce plateau ce soir
je suis pas je cherche pas être élogieux
en mai lui un élogieux
je pense qu'on a le droit aujourd'hui
dans une démocratie de critiquer
l'action d'un gouvernement notamment
quand on est dans l'opposition ça me
semble être un principe démocratique
mais surtout de le prouver
moi je ne suis pas je ne suis pas dans
les incantations jeu j'essaye de dire ce
que je pense ne pas aller dans le bon
sens et j'essaie de le prouver
vous pouvez me dire le contraire je
pense qu'à un rideau de fumée qui est
une communication qui est une
personnalité aussi et tout ça plutôt du
bon pour le pays c'est entraînant pour
le pays et c'est tant mieux mais je
pense qu'à partir du moment où ils à
avoir un effet d'entraînement que
n'aurait pas eu d'autres président de la
république alors il doit aller plus loin
dans les réformes je pense que si la
droite est au pouvoir aujourd'hui on
irait plus loin et plus vite dans les
réformes qui sont nécessaires qui sont
nécessaires pour le pays aujourd'hui le
président il évite toutes les réformes
qui sont difficiles
toutes les réformes sont difficiles sont
évite néanmoins voulu c'était un plein
succès dans ses entrevues je souhaite un
plein succès à mon pays et à notre pays
donc tout ce qui peut faire en sorte que
notre pays aille mieux qu'ils aient
moins de chômeurs qu'ils aient plus de
pouvoir d'achat que nos enfants et plus
dire qu'on retrouve la voix qu'on a
perdu sur le plan international tout ça
aura notre soutien encore faut-il que ce
soit la vérité et la réalité fait la
mairie ou demander un petit peu ce qu'on
arrête de dire nous voulons c'est un peu
ça ah je pense que c'est réellement une
insulte vis-à-vis de tous les français
merci beaucoup eric woerth d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci beaucoup
michael la semaine prochaine c'est le
député ex socialiste boris vallot qui
sera avec nous nous vous donnons la
parole puisqu'il fait partie peut-être
des éventuels prétendants pour reprendre
le parti dans les vélos il est toujours
soucié toujours socialiste effectivement
même si le nom du groupe à a eu un
nouveau patch le jeu nouvelle gauche
c'est la nouvelle gauche moi je veux pas
leur ferme à l'assemblée nationale voilà
qu'arrive un socialiste bonsoir à tous
et à la semaine prochaine